hello welcome to this video playing
pretty Capri trying this line again just
good score against I had this in an
earlier game and had a perfectly good
position which I totally screwed up now
it's not very well suited to win this
this opening but it's a very good line
of you once you get a solid position ok
so my tiguan b7 there would take with
the Queen ok let's do this d5 there's 95
so that shouldn't be so dangerous
Knight b6 was also possible with that
allowed Quincy 6 check so couldn't allow
that group c 8 has always answered by
Bishop 86 so that's not working I just
want a castle and then play this
position it's already a bit simplified
and it's got got the IQ p so let's
castle again d 5 is not possible yeah
just a like standard move like this
attacking that night no attack the night
and just have a look at if for so I
could take a for now stare I don't think
there's a particular reason not to take
it or is there some trap look a one-set
my blundering stuff I don't see it okay
you have to context therefore white is
essentially reduced to peace activity as
with a pawn gone you will win no end
game ever so I mean there was a scenario
of me losing the a pawn in some way and
um yeah did this kind of thing and then
the end game could could could occur but
this is this is a scenario it's not
happening after i take them take the
pawn okay so he wants to go once to play
against age seven that's a decent idea
of course maybe just go back here allow
the Queen to come over look at d5 look
at gt5 them okay i was thinking queen
d5a Susan is an idea you just turn a
centralized stuff chan in this case I'm
actually and attacking the rook oh I'm
blundering e700 stupid is that oh wow
oh that was cool just edged I just had
an extra corn for nothing and blended
this away that exactly the same thing
happened in the game before I had a porn
for nothing and then blundered it
amazing poor resign fufu yeah this is
just the engine gives white equality at
least so I wasn't better still giving
away this this is peace is just
ridiculous now simply simply didn't
register that this busy seven Bishop is
is loose so this is this is then just
losing group t7 is even stronger it
right it doesn't matter it's a piece so
I should go Queen d8 here and so what
the what the computer is giving what I'm
not quite understanding is what the
continuation is a 95 now is interesting
then there's
Jerry the engine likes white here and
he's got this cotton initiative I wasn't
thinking it is that dangerous to be
honest I know the comps which is to
rookie aid slight edge for wide yeah
maybe I shouldn't have taken this I
don't know but I think I can't believe
that that I cannot take the pawn I mean
the comp gives this is equal it's a move
that I so of course it's kind of normal
to play this just put this on the great
centralizing square on d5 but still so
here what can I improve here and queen
85 looks very very natural but the
alternatives Queens is six which was
mine which was something that i also had
considered but I thought rook see one
here and wasn't quite sure if I should
give him that they move
and then gives white compensation you
have to move like g4
however our time to leave that this is
enough for porn but I mean I have no no
big structure structural weaknesses that
I am skeptical my pieces are playing
some how but ok mean the computer gives
equal so it's tough to tough to now it's
probably tough to ever do something with
the airport as why it is so active I
mean even here I mean trade something
like this would be seven now why doesn't
widest active enough probably empty is
active enough yeah but I shouldn't still
shoot it planned at the bloody bishop
okay well thanks for watching